Traductor: Denise RQ
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
Las entrañas de la Biblioteca Beinecke
de libros raros y manuscritos en Yale,
albergan la única copia
de un tomo de 240 páginas.
La reciente datación por carbono 14
fecha esta copia alrededor de 1420
con sus páginas escritas a mano
en vitela con una tipología exquisita
e ilustrada con imágenes
de ensueño dibujadas a mano.
Plantas reales y quiméricas
castillos flotantes,
mujeres que se bañan,
horóscopos,
anillos del zodiaco,
y soles y lunas con caras
humanas acompañan el texto.
Este libro de 24x16 centímetros
se llama el manuscrito Voynich,
y es uno de los más grandes
misterios sin resolver de la historia.
¿Por qué?
Nadie puede averiguar lo que dice.
El nombre proviene de Wilfrid Voynich,
un librero polaco que encontró
el documento en una universidad jesuita
en Italia en 1912.
Estaba perplejo.
¿Quién lo escribió?
¿Dónde se hizo?
¿Qué representan estas extrañas
palabras y poderosos dibujos?
¿Qué secretos esconden sus páginas?
Compró el manuscrito universitario
al sacerdote necesitado de dinero
y finalmente lo trajo a EE. UU.
donde los expertos han continuado
investigándolo durante más de un siglo.
Los criptólogos afirman
que la escritura tiene
todas las características
de una lengua natural
solo que no corresponde
a ningún lenguaje concreto.
Lo que hace que parezca real es
que en los idiomas reales
las letras y grupos de letras
cumplen con la lay de Zipf
y el lenguaje en el manuscrito Voynich
presenta patrones que no se encuentran
en series aleatorias de símbolos.
Aparte de eso, sabemos poco
más de lo que podemos ver.
Las letras varían en estilo y tamaño.
Algunas corresponden a otros
códigos, pero muchas son únicas.
Las letras más altas han
sido denominadas horcas.
El manuscrito está muy decorado
y ornado como lo eran los pergaminos.
Parece estar escrito por dos o más manos,
y las ilustraciones por un tercero.
Con el paso del tiempo,
han surgido tres teorías principales
sobre el texto del manuscrito.
La primera es que está escrito en código
un código secreto diseñado adrede
para ocultar su significado secreto.
La segunda es que el documento
es un engaño, es pura galimatías,
para sacar dinero de un comprador crédulo.
Algunos especulan que el autor
fue un timador medieval.
Otros, que fue el propio Voynich.
La tercera teoría es que el manuscrito
está escrito en un idioma existente
pero en un código desconocido.
Tal vez los eruditos medievales
intentaron crear un alfabeto
para un idioma que se hablaba
pero no se escribía aún.
En ese caso, el manuscrito de Voynich
sería parecido al código rongorongo
inventado en Isla de Pascua,
que permanece ilegible
ya que su cultura desapareció.
Aunque nadie puede leer
el manuscrito Voynich,
eso no ha impedido que la gente
adivine lo que podría esconder.
Los que creen que el manuscrito
fue un intento por crear
un nuevo lenguaje escrito
especulan que podría ser una enciclopedia
que recoge el conocimiento de toda
una cultura correspondiente.
Otros creen que fue escrito por
el filósofo Roger Bacon en el siglo XIII,
quien intentó descifrar las leyes
universales de la gramática,
o en el siglo XVI por el místico
isabelino John Dee,
que era alquimista y predecía el futuro.
Otras teorías alternativas afirman que es
obra de un grupo de brujas italianas,
o incluso de los marcianos.
Después de 100 años de frustración,
los científicos han arrojado
un poco de luz sobre el misterio.
El primer avance fue
la datación con carbono 14.
Los historiadores contemporáneos
siguieron la pista del manuscrito
hasta Roma y Praga alrededor de 1612,
cuando quizás el Emperador Rudolf II
del Sacro Imperio Romano Germánico
lo regaló a su médico, Jacobus Sinapius.
Además de estos
descubrimientos históricos,
investigadores lingüísticos
han propuesto recientemente
la identificación provisional de algunas
de las palabras del manuscrito.
¿Podrían las letras "Tauran"
al lado de estas siete estrellas,
referirse a Tauro
la constelación formada por siete
estrellas llamadas las Pléyades?
¿Podría esta palabra leerse "Centaurun"
y referirse a la planta
Centaurea ilustrada más abajo?
Tal vez, pero hay pocos adelantos.
Si pudiéramos descifrar
su código, ¿qué descubriríamos?
¿El diario de ensueño de
un ilustrador del siglo XV?
¿Un montón de tonterías?
¿O el conocimiento perdido
de una cultura olvidada?
¿Y tú qué crees que significa?